WESTBROOK PLAYING DOWN THE
STRETCH HERE.
WESTBROOK ON THE DRIVE.
FEEDS JAMES.
JAMES GETS INSIDE, LAYS IT UP,
HE MISSED IT.
REBOUND KNOCKED LOOSE.
PICKED UP BY THOMPSON.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO FOUL.
THERE'S ABOUT A 5.5-SECOND
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN SHOT CLOCK
AND GAME CLOCK.
FIVE ON THE 24.
CURRY, A THREE.
REBOUND WESTBROOK.
AND THE LAKERS QUICKLY CALL
THEIR FINAL TIME-OUT WITH 7.3
SECONDS REMAINING.
WE'LL ADVANCE THE BALL IN THE
FRONT COURT AND HAVE A CHANCE TO
TIE IT AND FORCE OVERTIME.
SO, OF COURSE, THE QUESTION WE
ALWAYS ASK, GUYS, DO THE GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS FOUL?
THEY'VE GOT A LOT OF TIME, 7.3
SECONDS.
IT'S ALWAYS A TRICKY SITUATION,
BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, WHAT COMPICATES IT,
PARTICULARLY FOR THE WARRIORS,
IS THEIR LACK OF SIZE AND
THEY'RE NOT A GOOD REBOUNDING
TEAM.
SO, I STILL WOULD DO IT, BUT THE
WARRIORS HAVE A DIFFERENT GROUP.
THEY'RE JUST NOT BIG AND THEY
DON'T REBOUND THE BALL WELL.
>> Mike: MARK?
>> Mark: I WOULD FOUL IN THIS
SITUATION.
IT BOILS DOWN TO SECURING A
REBOUND OFF A MISSED FREE THROW.
WE GOT THE RIGHT HABITS TO DO
THAT.
>> Mike: THESE TWO TEAMS
THROWING HAY MAKERS AT EACH
OTHER.
KLAY THOMPSON LEADING THE WAY.
LAKERS PLAYING SOME INSPIRED
BASKETBALL ON THE ROAD IN A GAME
THEY TRAILED BY 15 EARLIER.
THOMPSON MAGNIFICENT, BUT NOW
THE LAKERS WITH A CHANCE.
>> Jeff: I THINK IT'S VERY
INTERESTING THAT THE LAKERS HAVE
KEPT ANTHONY DAVIS IN THE GAME
WHEN THEY NEED A THREE, WITHOUT
EITHER A WAYNE ELLINGTON OR AN
AVERY BRADLEY.
>> Mike: THEY HAVE TO GET IT
INBOUNDS, OBVIOUSLY, BECAUSE
THEY'RE OUT OF TIME-OUTS.
>> Mark: THIS IS THE SIDE OF THE
FLOOR THAT LeBRON LOVES THAT
SET-BACK THREE.
SOMETHING TO WATCH FOR.
>> Mike: WESTBROOK TO MALIK
MONK.
MONK, KICKS IT OUT, JAMES.
JAMES PUTS UP THE SHOT -- WON'T
GO, REBOUND, REAVES, BUT A
WHISTLE AND A FOUL.
>> Jeff: ON CURRY.
>> Mike: CURRY ARGUING.
THEY HAVE ALREADY USED THEIR
CHALLENGE.
CANNOT CHALLENGE IT.
AS CURRY PICKS UP THE PERSONAL.
AND JIM CAPERS, HE SIGNALED
THREE FREE THROWS.
HE'S NOW DISCUSSING IT.
>> Jeff: WHETHER IT WAS BEFORE
AND IT WAS DEFINITELY BEFORE.
BEFORE HE GOT INTO THE UPWARD
SHOOTING MOTION.
>> Mike: WELL, HE CLEARLY
DISCUSSED IT WITH HIS OFFICIALS
AND -- THEY DIDN'T KNOW IF THE
CALL WAS IN THE ACT OF SHOOTING.
SO, JAMES WILL SHOOT FREE
THROWS, HE'S 4 OF 6 TONIGHT.
ON THE SEASON, HE'S AT 75%.
THERE'S STILL 2.4 SECONDS
REMAINING.
AND HE MISSED THE FIRST.
SO NOW HE'S GOT TO HIT THE
SECOND AND MISS THE THIRD.
>> Mark: THAT'S THE ONLY OPTION.
THIS CROWD IS ELECTRIC.
AND LOONEY COMES INTO THE GAME
FOR REBOUNDING PURPOSES, BUT
THEY'RE STILL SMALL.
>> Jeff: I WOULD THINK ABOUT
PUTTING DWIGHT HOWARD IN RIGHT
NOW.
>> Mike: JAMES HAS TO WAIT UNTIL
THE BALL HITS THE RIM.
GOES IN THE LANE ON THE RELEASE.
THAT'S WHEN THEY CAN GO IN.
HIGH ONE.
TAKES A CAROM.
PORTER HAD IT, PICKS UP BY
JAMES, PUTS IT UP -- THAT'S IT.
GOLDEN STATE WINS.
WHAT A THRILLER TONIGHT HERE IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Jeff: JAMES TOOK A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT APPROACH.
A HIGH ARCING MISS.
NEVER SEEN THAT BEFORE.
HE GETS A GREAT BOUNCE AND IF HE
COULD HAVE GOTTEN IT CLEANLY, HE
WOULD HAVE HAD A LOOK.
>> Mark: I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU
SAID.
DWIGHT HOWARD, DeANDRE JORDAN
INTO THE BALL GAME FOR
REBOUNDING PURPOSES, BUT IT
WORKED OUT FOR THE LAKERS.
RAN OUT OF TIME.
HOW ABOUT THE HUSTLE BY STEVE
KERR, GETTING OUT OF THE WAY.
>> Mike: JAMES UNABLE TO HIT THE